left-hander cole irvine will start for
the is tonight
he's 4-7 a 3-8-9 era last pitched on
saturday in colorado and boy was he good
so that'll bring up salvador perez perez
277
14 homers 40 runs battered and two on
top of the first no score
and a five ball center field playable
cannon went back
now coming on still racing in and he
makes a lunging catch
got fooled by the swing that had to race
in and on the dead run
took that little short fly ball right
around his left knee
and so the royals go down one two three
with the a's coming up in the bottom
half brady singer
who was drafted number one by the royals
out of the university of florida back in
2018 will make his 13th start in the big
leagues this year
and mitch is a good matchup for singer
might be the toughest matchup of the
night as moreland
does very well against two seam
fastballs and
that is what singer features
and the pitch swung on ms he struck him
out on a slider
the yeas lead two we head to the second
inning of play
the royals nothing the age andrew
benintendi the former red sox
here's the one-off pitch it's swung on a
high pop third base side
foul territory long run for chat but
he's going to get there and he makes a
great running catch
stumbles falls down on the pitcher's
mounds in the ace bullpen
what a play by chapman and really no
regard for his body down there
full out racing with the ample foul
territory at the coliseum
hits the pitchers mounds takes a header
and holds on for out number one
and that will bring aramis garcia to the
plate
next pitch swung on and miss struck him
out good slider breaking down and away
from the right-handed hitter
so the royals get out of trouble again
in the second we head to the third
one away here's michael taylor one two
inside corner strike three call taylor
knew he was had
he's gone to looking strikeout number
one for cole irvin
up will step matt olsen their first
baseman also having an excellent year 15
homers 15
doubles he walked his first time up 2-2
and a swing and a miss he strikes him
out with a fastball
and brady singer with his third strike
out of the night in his first
1-2-3 inning we go to the fourth in
oakland no score
merefield drilled one to left center but
that's where kemp was positioned
and he is now giving up the entire left
field corner
he's past the out-of-town scoreboard in
his positioning
the wine the lefties one-two swing and a
miss fastball up and away at 91.
and mirrorfield has gone on strikes a
couple of k's for urban
that intended when he connected left on
left against jesus lizardo last night
here no score in the fourth two on one
out the pitch
breaking ball strike three caught on the
outside corner
stayed with the slider and bentendi is
gone looking
second out of the inning third k of the
night for cole
and now here comes jorge solaire the set
and the offer
swung on fly ball right center field
it's going to stay in the park for
canada and for brown who's going to get
it
it's going to be canada taking over in
right center makes the catch
urban avoids trouble
lions one toward the left field corner
it is
fair moreland comes in to score
chapman dig it for second he's got an
rbi double
here's seth brown
seth brown unloads on brady singer
kept on carrying and scores matt chapman
to make a three-nothing oakland his
ninth home run of the year and rbis 22
and 23.
gutierrez is all for one bounce to short
here's the o2 pitch and swung out of
miss right there back
down and in again off speed fourth
strikeout for irvin
marcan of the batter twice he's grounded
out to short
cannon takes his time digging back in
singer gets a sign from salvador perez
here's the pitch got him on a slide or a
swing and a miss and struck him out
four strikeouts for brady singer tonight
kemp reached out an error in the first
and then uh grounded out in the third
singer trying to keep him quiet here's
the pitch fastball
popped up foul territory over goes
gutierrez does he have room
oh he bobbles the ball and then does
make the catch just in front of the
oakland dugout
he went to make a basket catch and he
clipped off the heel of his glove
but bout straight up in the air about
four feet
giving him a chance to recover and then
make the catch that's a
nice juggling act how about sean vinaya
[Applause]
salvador perez may be the all-star
catcher for the american league
in the all-star game next month we'll
see he's going to lead off this
seventh inning salvi has singled and
flied to center
[Applause]
and there's a ball that's hit well down
the left field line that ball is gone
a home run for salvador perez pulls it
down the left field line and the royals
are on the board it's three to one
for salvi home run number 15 on the year
the batter will be michael a taylor who
had a hit in the ninth inning last night
his only hit of the series so far
tonight he's struck out looking
and he has flied to shallow right cole
irvine the starter nervously watching
from the top step of the dugout 2-0
pitch swing and a liner
on a couple of hops to the shortstop in
and out of his glove a run scores from
third the royals are within one
it's three to two and now it's the top
of the order and man this is tough with
whitmerfield who sprays line drives
all over the place here's the 3-1
swung out broken about flair toward the
second baseman it's caught by lowry and
the inning
is over petite hangs in there benz
doesn't break
one unearned run is home and the lead
stays
intact so that will bring salvador perez
to the plate
beekman's pitch swung on and hit high in
the air
deep to left field backing up his kemp
and that ball
is out of here a tie game
salvador perez belts it out and the
royals have locked up this game
at 3-3 and they're going to go righty on
righty with fravino against dozier
and ben and cindy is running and the
pitch is swung on and blooped into right
center field a long run and canada's not
going to get it
and ben and tendy goes from first to
third now the ball comes into the
infield the throw by olsen to the plate
and out at the plate and what will the
ears do with merrifield
and here's the o2 pitch swing on lifted
to right shallow but it's playable
and brown is going to get there about
two steps toward the line he makes the
catch
these made the right call pitching to
merrifield dyson left his second
and clutch pitching by lou gervino we go
to the bottom of the ninth he
is trying to win it is three in the
royal three so elvis andrews a chance to
be a hero he's one for three tonight
and here's the pitch again elvis swung
on line to right a base hit
chavez the third up with the ball with
dyson here's the throw to the plate
and it's going to be close to dive the
tank safe at the plate
and the a's have wanted